you
this year the award Israel to Baba Shem
Baba would you come up and join me at
the podium survivorship is the same way
a bank limited professor of marketing
professor marketing and a director of
the strategic marketing management
executive program the Robert K Jay
Dickey silver apple award is an annual
award presented to a member of the GSB
faculty for his or her contributions to
alumni relations with special emphasis
on faculty support and participation in
Stanford Business School Alumni
Association programs father has given
countless talks and met with hundreds of
alums throughout the US and the world
including Argentina Australia China
Chile Denmark France India and Italy
this year alone he has three more trips
planned over winter break in Korea
Thailand and Vietnam due to his ability
to engage students and alums alike these
lectures in presents are in great demand
and because of us it is a great pleasure
to honor Bob a chef with a silver Apple
Award
you can see I had my second brain here
as I grow older I realized that I need
this brain all the time and just a few
days ago actually lost his brain and I
just felt that man I just couldn't I
just couldn't do things so it looks like
this is just really become my second
brain now anyway what I'm going to do
today is talk about decision-making in
general and then get into the specifics
about the GS PS or the GS peers DNA is
something that I've learned over the
course of the last five years since I've
been here but before I do all that quick
show of hands how many of you would say
that you are great at making decisions
surf hands it has to be more than that I
mean otherwise we have failed you right
okay so how many of you would say that
from time to time you have trouble
making decisions I'll get good good okay
so let's let's suppose that it's one of
those days you wake up and you feel that
you're suffering from this disorder that
is decision deficit disorder right right
now now that's what this order like that
but you know who knows with the
proliferation of all these disorders
this might come into being and on that
particular day you you just wish that
you could become mr. Spock right that is
this the small team character in Star
Trek I mean they have Vulcans are
evolved to have muted emotional
circuitry and is portrayed to be able to
make great decisions so for you wish
that you could become mr. Spock and
again based not on the portrayal in Star
Trek but also in terms of the wisdom of
the ages right that you know good
decisions are one that are made devoid
of emotions you want to rein in these
emotions and you want to make these
decisions in a purely analytical fashion
now should you really wish to become
like mr. Spock point other words is mr.
Spock that's geared to make good
decisions now by the way if anyone yeah
okay by the way I go it's going to be a
problem right now before we answered
these set of questions the malays mr.
spot best gear to become to make good
decisions we have to ask ask ourselves
another question which is much more
important and that is what does it mean
to make good decisions or what does it
mean to make bad decisions right now for
to answer that question we have to get
to the decision makers journey and then
focus on one of the goals of the
decision maker okay
so if you look at the decision makers
journey and I think about any decision
that you're made professionalize
personalized big decision small
decisions you would have gone through
these three different phases right on
three different pods the first is the
predicted utility pod so I mean just as
an example let us suppose that you are
going to make a very senior hire for
your organization and you're faced with
two candidates one candidate a I mean
she's someone who's got a lot of work
experience but maybe not that relevant
of that many years of work relevant
experience relevant for your industry
the other person is someone who has got
few years of work experience but more of
those of those years have been relevant
to industry and you're faced with a
straight of conflict right now at that
particular stage you have to make
predictions about the utility you're
going to derive from these options from
these candidates and then make up your
mind you know keep in mind that point in
time you're faced with all the
uncertainties you're going to be faced
with incomplete information but based on
all these predictions you have to go
ahead and make up your mind right that
is the predicted utility part then comes
the actual experience itself and this is
where you're going to be deriving
utility from the experience from the
candidate who has been hired and that is
what are going to shape your remembered
utility right all the memories of an
emotions and all these gains the
updating of your priors and so on that
is not only going to shape your
subsequent journey because this will
cycle through but can also influence
other individuals decision journey right
I mean there could be a classmate of
yours who calls you and say hey listen
you know what I'm making the same kind
of decision out here how to make a
senior hire how do you go about doing it
and you're going to share your
and that is going to come from the
remembered utility so now let's take a
look at what should be the goals of a
decision okay or a decision maker if you
think about it there's one goal when you
think about the predicted utility phase
especially if your decision is going to
be very important is you need to make
sure that you're doing due diligence
right that you're getting asked with
information out there reducing
uncertainty is out there so that you're
not falling prey to any biases you're
not violating some norms I mean that
could be economic norms some of which
have listed out there that could be
socio cultural norms legal norms and so
on and for most of you in this audience
I mean this is something that you
probably will not be doing but where you
are right now it'll be someone else
would be doing this you have your staff
was doing is the legal team doing this
and so on and this is where they're
going to come in here they're going to
do the due diligence and that's when
they're going to bring the options to
you and now you as the decision-maker
have to make up your mind right then
comes the second goal and that is you
want to emerge from that decision
feeling as confident as possible certain
that you made the right thing why
because if you don't do that if you're
not confident about the decision you're
just made you're not going to be in a
position to extract as much utility as
possible from the hire that you just
made you're not going to throw in the
resources to make us successful and so
on and so forth right and this is true
for any decision if you're not kind of
confident you're not going to be
extracting all this utility so that's
the second kind of goal that you have
that you've got to emerge from the
decision feeling confident you don't
want to be overconfident because you
will get into other biases which I'll
get to later on okay and the third one
is where you're going to have this goal
about remembered utility and that is you
want to learn from your mistakes you
don't want to be blinded through
information that subsequently starts
coming in some of them can be bad
infusing turned a negative in terms of
the decision that you are made you don't
want to be blinded you want update and
so on and and and move on and therefore
you're going to shape your subsequent
decision and so on
like I mean think about the three goals
that you have fidelity is going to be
this due diligence at the predict leader
2d phase you want to emerge from the
decision feeling confident so you're
able to
it'll be from the experience utility
part and the third one is this
remembered you today are doing the
updating and so on
now for the predominant chunk of my
presentation I'm going to focus on the
second one I will certainly touch upon
the other two but I'll focus on the
second one and therefore if you focus on
the second one we can ask a very simple
question and that is go back to mr.
Spock is he
best geared to make confident decisions
in other words you see going to emerge
from decisions looking very confident
and actually feeling confident but
that's how he's portrayed to be in Star
Trek but that could be invalid right so
we can ask this question and the problem
about answering this question is
unfortunately this is a fictional
character we don't have access to it
right we can conduct tests on him we can
observe him making decisions and
therefore we cannot come to our own
conclusions whether the portrayal in
those Star Trek episodes in the movie
etc is valid or not fortunately for us
we do have people who turn into mr.
Spock's
okay and it'll typically happen because
of an accident a disease almost
frequently what we observe will be
because of a stroke that will take away
areas of the emotional certificate now
you can actually now study them you can
actually observe them what happens to
them after they suffered this stroke we
just knocked off areas of the emotional
circuitry and control own conclusions
about you know if mr. Spock best geared
to emerge from a decision feeling
confident or not so that's what we're
going to do we'll start off with the
first story which is the unfortunate
story of Phineas Gage the first jury
about a person who became a mr. Spock
and some of you heard of this story
before
so bear with me if you have already
heard this before so here is a gentleman
it is said in the mid eighteen hundreds
1848 to be precise here's a railroad
worker in Vermont actually he's a
foreman so he's a manager of people
doing extremely well in life I mean
professionally he is very polite
respectful of authority and so on doing
reasonably well financially he's doing
extremely well socially in terms of
friends and so on unfortunately one day
he meets with an accident
there is an explosion that that drives a
tamping iron right this is a metal rod
about an inch in diameter which kind of
drives the tamping iron through his left
cheek bone and the tamping had just
emerges out of a skull Jesus right oh my
goodness
now he he he actually he actually
survives the accident crazy think about
it he actually survived the axe okay and
I'll get to that in just a second now
his skull is still preserved in one of
the museum's the Harvard Medical Museum
and was subject to what is called a
forensic neuroscience examination right
so these this team of researchers had
access to his skull and they could start
making predictions about which soft
tissues might have gotten damaged
because of this accident and what they
concluded was that this accident had
destroyed a very critical area of her
brains emotional circuitry and that is
the ventral medial prefrontal cortex so
for those of you who are familiar with
who practice Buddhist meditation this
would be referred to as the third eye
right so this is the human brain this is
where your eyeballs would be so it's the
front of the brain this is the ventral
medial prefrontal cortex the very very
critical area of emotional circuitry now
keep one thing in mind he had other
areas of the emotional circuitry intact
especially his amygdala now amygdala is
the center of the brain that typically
generates emotion
so you can understand that here's a
person after this area of the brain got
knocked off the ventromedial prefrontal
cortex his brain could still generate
emotion but his brain could not deploy
these emotion when the situation so
demanded so you gotta keep that in mind
okay now remember I said that he he
survives the accident of course he's in
a coma I mean this is coming so
traumatic obviously the person is going
to be in a coma to begin with go for
about a month he recovers now people
he's able to walk he's able to talk so
this did nothing to his
centers of the brain has motor centers
of the brain and so on but people began
to notice a marked change in his
personality and this was documented by
his doctor if you look at his doctor's
report nobody said that he was a person
who was responsible polite and so on now
becomes grossly profane using bad
language a lot of this unrestrained
behavior you know giving to bursts of
anger right but you have hi I have been
in meetings I'm sure you experienced
this when you don't even want to
strangle someone right you're so mad but
you don't do it you restrain yourself
because of the potential consequences he
wouldn't do that he'll get him do this
to rage and go to strangle people so
he's able to generate this emotion but
he's not able to control these emotions
right and the third thing that manifests
you can see in the doctor's report that
is most pertinent for the discussion at
hand is that here's a person who's
simply unable to make a decision he
adopts one course of action apparent
that and up another course of action
abandoned that he becomes like the
proverbial buridan's ass have you heard
about the story this Britain's ask the
proverbial here is a NASA donkey that
was kept between two bales of hay of
equal size and it literally stars itself
to death because if you don't decide
which way to go and so this accident
does damage to the emotional circuitry
has damaged his has made him into a
buridan's ass right now you can see this
manifesting itself throughout his life
in this one of the twelve years after
the accident he goes from job to job
from town to town he cannot stick to a
job he cannot stick to your town he
moves on finally ends up dying here in
San Francisco
it's okay I'll be a SATA after the
accident so first evidence recorded
evidence that maybe you know what mr.
spark will not be good at making
confident decisions unlike what has been
portrayed in Star Trek in those episodes
because he was a gentleman who loses an
area of the emotional circuitry and he
gets into this Britain's ass he's not
confident emerging from the decision now
of course this is a data point of one it
is anecdotal set in the mid 1800s
know what the doctor was doing and we
dissolved this a long time ago so I mean
you got to kind of take that with a
grain of salt right now this is where
you can see that you can examine
patients now patients who suffer
typically the patients that I have dealt
with when I was at the University of
Iowa before I came here
we're people who will suffer a stroke
that'd be a stroke they'd be rushed to
the University of Iowa Hospitals many of
them by helicopter
they'll be stabilized out there some of
them unfortunately will pass on but you
know but the people who survive will
immediately go and take a full brain
scan to find out which areas of the
brain have gotten damaged and you know
what we will then ask the patient and
you know the family members and so on is
would you like to be part of a registry
and the University of Iowa one of the
great things about that place was that
it is even today has one of the largest
registries of patients with brain damage
in different areas of the brain so we
asked them would you like to be part of
the registry what do you get in return
is that well I mean you could be brought
to the hospital's our our expense every
single year okay you'll be put up in a
hotel for two days even three days you
get free diagnostic tests and you can
take part in some fun studies and some
of the studies that we would conduct
them this is a study that was done is
where you would kind of so here is a
patient who we knew was going to come to
the University of Iowa Hospitals and we
beforehand about a month before we asked
send a list of gift items he would like
to take with him after his visit in was
divided our hospitals so this patient
had two items one was a pen and one was
a wallet right that's what he prefers
now he comes to the u.s. of Iowa
Hospitals and he is his dong his
diagnostic test is done his studies
another day he's supposed to go back to
his hotel and we offer him these two
gift items now if you and I are doing
this it's a very trivial decision if you
think about it you'll examine these to
think about it grab one go the patient
doesn't do that well the patient and
this will happen on outpatients as well
what they would do is they will examine
the two items they'll grab one
they'd hesitate and then they'll go to
the other one then sometimes walk out of
the room come back and take the other
item
many a time they'll actually go to the
hotel room and actually call us up and
say hey when we come and I come in
tomorrow morning can I pick up the other
item even for a simple decision like you
know a pen in the wallet okay
but keep in mind this only happens if
they're faced with a trade-off conflict
in other words the two items that are
equally preferred if what is preferred
to the other the pen in the wallet if
the pen is preferred to the wallet no
problems in making a decision right so
the way these patients cope in their
day-to-day lives because they have to
cope with this it's very often they'll
become brand loyal they don't want all
these multiple options give me one
option I can go with that okay so you
see this happening with them this this
kind of date the brain the emotional
area of the brain gets by the way this
will not show up in patients who also
suffered a stroke but that stroke didn't
damage areas of the emotional circuitry
it'll only happen with patients who
suffered damage to the emotional
circuitry so we have this accumulating
evidence now Phineas Gage to begin with
now these patients who have got damage
to the emotional circuitry that maybe
mr. Spock
maybe mr. Spock will be unable to emerge
from a decision feeling confident but
these are patients what about normal
human beings right can we observe this
and normal human beings as well and you
can not to the extent of these patients
so if I had administered a scale what is
called the effect intensity measure
scale it measures the intensity of the
emotion when you experience emotions how
intense is that emotion I've grabbed
administer that scale out here and what
I would have gotten from a scale is a
bell curve I would have gotten a normal
distribution
some people have extreme intense
emotions some people don't experience
emotions with that intensity now keep in
mind I just want to be very very clear
here that if I do this with you out here
you will have this bell curve but where
the patients would fall will be way off
this off the screen so it's just
relative by the way you still have an
intact emotional circuitry right now
what
whatever what I can then do once I get
this bell curve is that I can start
assigning labels to people who fall on
the on the upper end of the curve versus
people who follow the low end of the
curve and so just for the sake of
convenience what I would do is I would
label the people who fall here as
emotionals
and by the way these words have are not
loaded to have no loaded meanings at all
okay just for the sake of convenience
and I will label these people as welcome
just when I think of permanence there's
nothing loaded out here and what I will
observe is relative through the
emotionals
walkins will have greater trouble in
emerging from a decision feeling
confident now here's the fun part of the
story typically you'll find that if I
look at who constitute emotionals that
we have greater propensity of women
falling in the category if it's
happening in almost all the studies we
are done we look at women and really
they'll fall on that end of the category
and therefore in almost all the studies
that we have done in looking at decision
confidence we'll find that women make
better decisions than men do
except has to be accept right except in
one context can you guess up finding a
partner
and I'll get to that later on because
because I'll tell you why this happened
when I get into this arranged marriage
away a way of making a decision versus a
love marriage way of making a decision
okay I'll talk about that now the next
question if I'm going to administer the
scale here among GSB students and I'm
going to administer this to the unnamed
School of the East Coast where do you
think the GSB Rose would fall this I'm
getting into the first first you know
aspect a component of the GSB earth DNA
many think they befall mr. hood yeah any
guesses where they fall consistently
they would fall on the emotional end of
the spectrum it's consistently they
would fold it and therefore in general
you folks out here again and try to
happen I don't know how this happens it
maybe it's self selection what not is
going on but you'll generally see that
emotion and therefore in general they'll
be much more confident then students who
are at other institutions or competitors
okay in general and therefore jeans
beers in general also will have problems
with finding a partner and to cop on the
fact if you're a women and angeas beer
oh my goodness I mean that's going to be
okay I mean let us get behind the
science of all this but let us try to
conclude what we have all these
documented evidence what it is
suggesting is the following that you
know that emotion plays a very critical
role in allowing us to resolve conflicts
when we make our decisions and allow us
to emerge from the decision feeling as
confident as possible and therefore
allow us to extract as much utility from
the next part that's what that's what I
can conclude from all this support all
this accumulated evidence from patients
Phineas Gage and also but this emotion
was as welcome categorization the past
why what is it about the brains
architecture that is causing this right
now the way the brain goes about making
decisions it's not how the economists
would tell you to make a decision if
you're faced with a crate of conflict if
you face the threat of conflict where
you have two options a is equal to B
what the economist will tell you to do
is adopt what is called the completeness
principle the computerss principle would
say what it do is that you keep getting
information evaluating information about
the two options until a winner emerges
and then pick the winner or if you have
a deadline by which you buy both time
you had to make a decision
you keep acquiring this information and
by that time if you're still stuck with
a equals B just toss a fair coin and it
should be fine I mean that's what the
economist would say that's the complete
this principle the brain doesn't do that
what the brain does is that it might
start off the whole process but I'm
saying might underscore my because in
our research we're never found that in
all our research we found that right off
the back you're going to get a process
that is called pre positional Distortion
but let me back up for a moment why do
you find the brain doing it might start
off in an unbiased fashion and acquiring
all this information evaluating
information at some point in time and
very often very quickly you will have an
emotional signal what we call a somatic
marker that will go in favor of one of
the options and if I put you into a
functional magnetic resonance imaging
machine where I'm kind of monitoring the
entire brain activity we can actually
observe this emotional signal thereafter
what you have what the brain has created
with that emotional signal is an
emotional frontrunner they're after you
as a decision-maker might think that
you're being rational you are actually
engaging in what is referred to as
pre-decisional distortion of information
okay it is similar to dissonance that
happens after you make a decision it
happens actually even before you made a
decision and very often right happens
right off the bat now how do we document
this pre-decisional distortion we use a
task that is called the pre-decisional
distal
tasks okay so let me explain that for a
second so let us say that you have two
options a and B now let us say it is go
back to the example I gave you're going
to make this senior higher you have
these two candidates out there what I
would do here is that I'll present
information about the two candidates one
attribute at a time so let us say the
first attribute is the number of years
of work experience that's the first
attribute I'll then ask you based on
this information if I'm going to give
you a minus 5 to +5 scale but 0 being
the midpoint how much ahead is a
compared to be ok and let us say that in
terms of years of experience a has more
work experience than B and let us say
your response as an individual is going
to be a 2 on that scale which means
you're saying that based on this
information I think a is ahead of B by 2
points I'm going to plot it on a chart
like this the second piece of
information might be that this person a
has worked in more diverse countries has
much more global experience than B how
important now you're gonna ask you again
based on this information how far ahead
is a compact to be and let us say you
give a 1 I'm going to put on this chart
as a cumulative so you see it's 2 it
goes up to 3 or whatever right the third
piece of information might be the number
of years of a number of years of
experience relevant to your industry and
let us say there B does better than a so
are you going to say hey given this
information in this famous a I'm going
to give this a minus 1 or minus 2 you
see what I'm doing here with each
attribute I'm asking you to respond to
the scale and I'm just cumulating that
out there and what will happen if I
observe emotionals and I compare you
with controls now the control subjects
to go to the same task the only
difference is that instead of a and B
all through the process the first
attribute will be a and B the second
will be C and D the third will be e and
F and so on so you can't you can't
engage in any bias out here that'll be
the control I'll do the cumulate
and if I observe what emotionals would
do you'll get this beautiful fanning out
effect and we see this reliably among
these beers we'll find it reliably among
women
this beautiful Fanning art effect which
is why emotional so if you think about
it they have already disturbed because
the pre-decisional distortion they
discharge the information so much that
at the end of this process they have not
just a winner they have a clear winner
where a is not just greater than B a is
much greater than B as a result but the
big option a they're very confident
about the decision whereas if you're
welcome from you know their unnamed East
Coast cool you will observe something
like this and then of course I'm
exaggerating this I'm gonna gonna do
that
but but but it's going to be circular
that patients will be perfectly all on
the Green Line they won't show any
distortion at all and you can see why
walkins have the strap trouble emerging
from a decision feeling confident
because they're not dis charting this
information as much as what isn't the
which they come to the sixth piece of
information they're still stuck it's
almost close to one another if they pick
a they still are confident that point of
times I say but a second will let you
change your mind and go to B let's say
okay I'll go to be in your mind again
and good it okay I'll go to it they'll
go back and forth and back and forth
right now remember you see that this
this phenomenon here this huge kind of
same part of the GSB s DNA this is the
same thing that can also give rise to a
bias that can come to bite you as GS
peers and that is the escalation of
commitment bias where you're throwing
good money good resources after bad
decisions it's the same process you're
made up in mind now you start getting
all this negative information what does
the brain do it just damn sit down you
become blind you become blind to it so I
I kind of advised many of these students
right hook we're getting into startup
mode in fact it's they are they already
started doing that this MBA tools and
you know winter it'll be full-blown out
there I'm gonna advisory boards of
several startups around here in Silicon
Valley
my job as a mentor as an advisor always
with GS beers is raining them air
because they will just take the idea and
start running and become completely
blind to all the information that is
coming in that suggests that wait a
second
maybe you got a device your opinion
about the decision you made maybe you've
got to be flexible
you won't observe that happening and
therefore my job is to bring that thing
inside right now so if we think about it
the trick for GSP is if you share this
DNA if you think that you share this DNA
that I've just highlighted now that is
your much more emotion on the emotional
end of the spectrum than the Vulcan end
of the spectrum the trick is when to
leverage emotion the emotional side of
the equation and when to move and push
the levers on the Vulcan side right and
we look at how you can go about flipping
the switch on the Vulcan side because
that'll become relevant in certain
contexts right and by the way let me
also highlight the one advantage few
folks have is that it is easier to
switch from being an emotional to a
Vulcan than the other way around it's
very difficult to move from being a
Vulcan to to an emotional okay so let us
look at some of the factors okay the
first factor remember this curve the
first in attribute that I presented if
you recall was the number of years of
work experience but let us say instead
of that I had presented you with the
salary that is going to be demanded that
is the attribute was related to a number
to price it would have turned you into a
walcker
it all turned in welcome and that's why
I tell people who are in sales and I
used to be in sales before I came to
academia is that the first and only rule
of thumb in sales is that even if you're
working for a price leader okay where
you're pushing never lead the charge
with price because that in turn your
customer your client into a Vulcan okay
so first factor is price so if you have
a team of staffers who are doing the due
diligence and you don't want them to
fall prey to the bias it behooves you to
get them to focus on the numbers so that
even if their emotions out there they
will turn into Vulcans right so one of
them is price second does anything that
is going to force you to become
analytical so if I'm
if I'm going to force you to present
information on read information the form
of charts in the form of numbers and
tables and so on tell Tony or Malcolm
now the other factor this is relevant
again for the GSB is DNA is what is your
mindset okay and here I can categorize
people as having two different mindset
these are terms that I borrowed from
statistics even remember your statistics
from your old days right you say that
you can you can create two kinds of
errors in statistics right what does it
type one error
right where you're fearful of committing
a mistake you're making a decision that
turns to sound that is a type 1 error a
type 2 error is where you're fearful of
missing out on an opportunity and you'll
find in general people also have these
mindsets and there are these huge
individual differences and one of the
things that I have learned over a period
of time about the GSB s DNA is that
they'll be typically type 2 individuals
this fear of losing out on an
opportunity and you'll see this
manifesting itself and when I go to
alumni reunions especially the younger
people who come over here you could have
seen that you people have have started a
company failed start another company
failed no problem they show up for the
Union you go to that other unnamed
institution or the East Coast if someone
has done that they won't show up because
to fail if you're a type 1 mindset is
shameful whereas what is shameful for
the GSB R is not failure it is someone
else picking up an opportunity and
running with it and you were there in
the sidelines and that's why you commit
this is as classic GS beers DNA ok which
is again good it goes in your favor
let me tell the last factor for the sake
of completeness and I want to kind of
focus on this because this is something
that you have to be very mindful of you
have everything going for you you're the
mostly out of the spectrum and you also
have this type two mindset
and that is sleep of all the factors of
all the factors that we see one of the
surefire ways you will turn into a
Vulcan is not getting enough sleep in
adequate sleep okay
and one of the most important and the
question is why does this happen it
happens because if you think about sleep
and look up with a different stages of
sleep there are two stages or two phases
in your sleep that are critical for
decision-making one is the REM sleep
rapid eye movement sleep and I'll tell
you why that is important and the other
one is stage 3 and stage 4 that is deep
sleep deep sleep is important because
that is when all your neuromodulators
are coming back to normal dopamine and
especially serotonin the calming
chemical if you don't get enough deep
sleep what's going to happen is that
serotonin levels come down hard to saw
levels the stress chemical goes up and
you're going to turn into a type 1
cortisol goes up you become fearful of
committing a mistake right the second
one is that if you look at the REM sleep
that is when all the memories are
getting what is a phenomenon called
binding right so what we observe today
your Hall does you listen to the talk
you've seen all this brand eventual
media all these things happening out
here what is happening is that when you
get into this REM sleep is when all this
information starts getting bound to your
previous knowledge structures okay and
this is also when your emotions to the
various options start getting back and
if you don't get REM sleep you're going
to be faced with options which are
emotionless and therefore you'll turn
into Walter what is amazing for me is
that think about the number of decisions
in the world in c-suites out there
boardrooms out there the particularly
now out there were the key players are
coming to the decision with inadequate
sleep amazes me all the time right now
if I don't know how am i doing on time
I'm supposed to get done can someone
healthier
okay so I have I have done maybe I
should let me tell you a story okay
since I have the time so okay so this is
my technology comes and as some of you
have heard of this device called Zeo
we heard of this called the device
called Zeo it's a nice I don't want to
put in a plug there so maybe I have and
by the way I have nothing to do with the
company okay I have no investment and so
on but it's a great product so what it
is essentially an EEG machine it has got
a base device or base out there that is
a clock and so on and you have wear a
headband that has got three electrodes
that measure your EEG wave throughout
the entire sleep episode okay so it
takes a sampling every five minutes
now at the end of the sleep episode if
your slept for seven hours eight hours
so to tell you what percentage of the
sleep was light sleep was deep sleep was
REM sleep so I get hold of this device
and I start wearing it right the first
day I look at it and I say I have only
18 minutes of deep sleep in an
eight-hour sleep episode and I go
something wrong let me think about it
I meet for one week or one month in a
full year and I'm done with teaching I'm
not stressed like many of you are right
I mean I should not I should be getting
a lot of deep sleep but no and I said
wait a second you know what maybe
something wrong with the device it's
what your first thing you do right I'm
gonna blame the device no let me try it
out and see how it is she's getting the
our our brief slave hour-and-a-half my
son uses the ten years old three hours
of deep sleep I usually again and it's
11 minutes of deep sleep what's going on
here right and the nice thing about the
device is that it you can kind of
there's an SD card you take out of the
device get into the computer that's a
personal journal so it passed a lot of
questions like when do you work out in a
day and I say I work out in the mornings
and no I recorded afternoons and it says
why don't you work out in the mornings I
say sure and I can do it right I'm so
flexible I teach for only one month in
the year so I can do that so I do that
it makes a small bump or not of a
difference and finally has to be going
through all the iterations and finally
Bassem okay do consume alcohol and I
said yeah I'd like to consider a glass
or a couple of glasses of wine
so it says okay why don't you move that
by an hour advance the pair an hour
boom goes from 1820 minutes to 3035
minutes just right off the bat
and then it says moving down to the hour
I do it goes up again right of course I
had to stop something like this I'd be
drinking at this point in time but
that's why I think technology is coming
in in terms of this you think about the
last Tour de France all the players all
I mean all the cyclists out there made
use of that device and you'll see the
technology emerging in the future where
you're allowing technology to help you
with recommendation agents what to eat
when to do what
and so on and so forth to improve sleep
it's called Zeo Zeo you can check it out
anyway so um what we have discussed so
far is if your goal and that is an
important thing I won't underscore that
if your goal in decision making is to
emerge from the decision feeling as
confident as possible right you want to
make sure that you're leveraging the one
part of the DNA that you have and that
is you fall in the emotional end of the
spectrum now they're going to be
exceptions right there are going to be
situation we have seen them for example
if you're doing due diligence you don't
want to fall prey to biases you want to
flip the Vulcan switch out there right
if you're kind of you don't want if
you're if you think that after making a
decision you're falling prey to the
escalation of commitment bias there's
again you got to flip the Vulcan switch
now what I'm going to do is present two
other contexts where we have this
documented evidence where being an
emotional is actually going to hurt okay
and what is them is going to be why
women have trouble finding a partner
okay but before you that good leave that
as a suspense after all you got to leave
something for a suspense right this way
it's a thought experiment so let us say
that you come into the study and I'm
going to tell you that you're going to
make several rounds of investment
decisions I'm not going to tell you how
many rounds it's a large number of
rounds and I'm going to endow you with
$20 in $1 bills and I'm going to tell
you the way the game is going to proceed
is the foreman on any round you can
decide to pass in which case I'll take
you to the next round
or you could decide to invest a dollar
if you decide to invest a dollar
I'm gonna toss a fair coin had you lose
the investment you lose the dollar tails
I'm going to add a dollar fifty two
investment it's almost like stocks and
bonds right now what I have to do I mean
your goal if you're not dealing with
finish we risk out here we're gonna say
your job your task at the end of the day
you should leave the table but as much
money in your pocket as possible you
know that it is pretty obvious given the
structure of the task you should just
keep investing in every single round
right because the expected value from
investing is greater it's a dollar
twenty-five is much greater than
expected value of not investing in this
particular tax you'll just keep blindly
investing in other words what you should
do optimally given this economic norm of
expected values you should just keep
investing in every single Braun and yet
you'll see normal individuals and this
was not documented by us it was first
documented by by research behavioral
economists at Chicago they had students
trained in economics they have students
trade in finance and the pattern they
will manifest is like the following they
will start off close to what is optimal
and then they'll start putting on the
brakes by the time they're on to the
20th rod we run this for twenty rounds
they'll be investing in only 50% of the
runs now the question is why right
the reason this happens is that when you
stop this task you know what to do your
cognitive brain knows that I have to
invest and therefore you're gonna invest
now you invested I'm gonna pass a fair
coin there's an outcome if you win you
go yeah that's an emotion if you lose
you go oh that's an emotion right now
you get on to the next round if you copy
the brain is saying invest invest invest
but you have this emotional baggage now
let us come from the previous job if
it's a win if it's a loose you would say
oh I won't be fearful now if it's a win
I'm gonna say well maybe I should maybe
I'm not and so on and so forth right you
could be lucky I got lucky I got to be
careful and so all these emotions are
coming in by the time you're to the 10th
and twelve rounds you had some positives
you had some negative outcomes positive
emotions negative emotions and in
general unless you are a functional
psychopath and there are believe me
functional Psychopaths for whom positive
emotions will outweigh negative emotions
when these two emotions will impinge on
a needle structure for most individuals
negative is going to far outweigh the
positive and so what happens you're
under the culture on there are some
winsome losses that are negative
positive all this in putting on the
neural circuitry ultimately the
emotional side of the brain is going to
say mMmmm don't invest now don't invest
on invest if I stop you at that point in
time and ask you what are you doing you
will come up with a story to justify
your decision because you can articulate
it these emotions are all kind of
guiding us in a very non conscious level
okay so so far you can see this is a
proposition that I can make what I call
a freeing key proposition the class that
I teach out here for only a month every
single day four sections of it it's
called the freaky signs of the human
mind what's tricky Frankie there's a
word like that right it's funky and
freaky Frankie
so here is a freaky prediction I can
make I can say that if I take the same
patients who had suffered a stroke which
knocked off areas of the emotional
circuit it yes they actually brain
damage and I put them into this task the
same brain-damaged patients who don't
have this emotional circuitry will now
outperform normal individuals will
outperform those economists and those
finance students at Chicago that's what
I can predict right now to do the test
of course I need to have a control which
will be also people who have suffered
damage to because of a stroke damage to
the brain but didn't take away areas of
the emotional circuitry these are called
the lesion controls take them to this
task they also have the normal
individuals and what we document is
something like that you see the top
curve was flat these are
patients who suffered damage to be
emotional circuitry then you have the
other people the novel individuals and
the lesion controls show this classic at
a situation where they start off close
to optimal and then as a task begins to
proceed they put on the brakes so here's
where I have my only claim to fame and
that is appearing in a Jay Leno Show not
I mean not appearing my research
appearing in a Jay Leno Show I want to
kind of share that with you so fun
damage choose to be a brain damaged
outperform normal healthy people in
investing so here try to make money in
the stock market you feel like you're
banging your head against the wall bang
okay let's get into the other
interesting thing now and then we'll
finish up and hopefully we'll have time
for a couple of questions and that is if
you look at systematic led women and
also we have seen this with GSB years
who are the emotional side of the
spectrum you see that you know they'll
have trouble making what are called
sequential decisions compared to making
simultaneous decisions so what is the
difference breathe into the simultaneous
decision is like an arranged marriage
way of making a decision here you have
all the options presented to you at one
shot by the way this is not just in
finding a partner it can happen in for
example making an investment private
equity you can have you know either your
staffers come and bring up you to three
different options so that's a
simultaneous decision right and your job
there is to pick the best among the
options that has been presented right
the goal out there is focus on one of
the options that have been presented in
a sequential choice or a loud marriage
way of decision it's very different what
you have to do you have an option right
now maybe an individual you're dating or
so on so forth there's your house option
and your decision right now is whether I
should stick to that option or move on
to the next option and very often if you
think about it in finding a partner
you're finding private equity investment
and so on very often the other option is
an unknown right you have the known
burden bush and you're comparing that
with an unknown unknown bird in hand and
unknown bird in the bush and yet what
you would do you'll kind of go on to the
next option and then the next option
either the next option and so on and
therefore in this research what the
question that we ask is if I put you
through this as emotionals
and put it through some of you through a
simultaneous decision-making task and
you pick an option
some of you through a sequential risky
decision-making task then you pick an
option who among you is going to feel
more constant
after having made the decision and what
I'll systematically find out is the
people who have made sequential choices
especially the emotional will be much
less confident now the question is why
right the reason this happens if we go
back to this one
is that in the sequential
decision-making you have two emotions
that come into play one is hope and it
specifically happens for successful
people because successful people are
eternal optimists and therefore you
think that the next option is going to
be better than the present option and
there is this emotion of hope that is
driving you away from the present option
to the next option
second is this emotion of fear fear of
being stuck with an inferior option a
game driving you to the next option and
that is the reason you'll see this
happening boom boom they'll keep going
and after they've made the decision
after me after they make those decisions
they're not confident about the decision
that they are made and I've called this
phenomenon as the constant search for
the right the right person the right end
of the bell curve right I mean you have
a pleasant option who's falling in the
85th percentile
you should be happy with that and then
you move on to the next option why
because you think the next option is
going to be better than the present
option life is not that kind right I
mean life art that never delivers it in
that fashion and they decipher the next
option is going to be worse than that
because that's how the bell curve is
going to be shaped it's going to be
worse off than the present option right
anyway that's why I call this as the
constant search for the right okay I'm
done I just want to give us a few key
takeaways out here from this talk so all
I'm saying is that I mean if if there's
any learning from this one is that if
your goal is to be decisive and
confident after after emerging from a
decision first is especially for those
of you who have would feel that you have
the
fear DNA is to make sure that you
leverage emotion number one and number
two make sure that if possible at all
try to make simultaneous decisions
rather than sequential decisions now if
you finding a partner and in this
culture you can't afford to have a
simultaneous choice I mean some people
do it successfully date multiple women
and then decide that or men and so on
and then that doesn't happen it has to
be sequential right now if you're faced
with that context but you're forced to
make a sequential decision then what I
would advise you to do is create
benchmarks in other words when I do this
for price especially in private equity I
kind of do this is that when people are
faced with situational decisions I'll
force the decision-maker
to tell me what were the past successes
and past failures and what I would do is
ask the person compared this one to your
past success and tell me is it as good
or better than the best what that is
doing is shifting you from a Maximizer
and most of us in our lives being
successful because we are maximizes we
want the best in life right it is
forcing you to switch from being a
Maximizer to a satisficer in other words
you're adopting now a threshold model
rather than the best option model make
sense now of course you've got to be
mindful of when these emotions are going
to be detrimental to your
decision-making when you're doing due
diligence you don't want to fall prey to
the escalation of commitment bias when
there are norms out there and thank you
very much